نحن متحمسون جدًا لتعريفك
بجهاز iPhone 10 R ، إنه أمر مذهل تمامًا ،
فهو يأتي بلمسات نهائية جديدة لا تصدق ،
أبيض ، أسود ، أزرق ، أصفر مرجاني ،
كل تصميم جميل مع هذا
اللمسة النهائية المصنوعة من الألومنيوم ، هذه الشاشة هي حقًا
ما يذهلك على الرغم من أنها شاشة LCD
لأول مرة  يذهب من
الحافة إلى الحافة ، فقد استغرق الأمر
هندسة وتكنولوجيا جديدة متطورة للقيام
بإخفاء البكسل وصقل البكسل والحصول
على مصابيح LED تتناسب مع مساحة أصغر
من أي وقت مضى ، هذه هي
شاشة LCD الأكثر تقدمًا في أي هاتف ذكي
وهي تجربة iPhone 10  على شاشة LCD ،
وهذا يعني أنك تنقر
عليه لإيقاظه ، فلا يوجد زر الصفحة الرئيسية الآن ،
ليس به لمسة ثلاثية الأبعاد ، ولكن هنا مرة أخرى ،
توصل الفريق إلى شيء ذكي حقًا ،
إنها ميزة جديدة نسميها البصريات اللمسية
حتى يتسنى لك الوصول إليها  الكاميرا من الشاشة الرئيسية
التي تضغط عليها للتو ، ستشعر
بنقرة لمسية ويتم نقلك مباشرة
إلى الكاميرا ولديها نظام كاميرا جديد رائع
بالإضافة إلى
نظام كاميرا واحد أفضل كاميراتنا المنفردة  ystem
لقد صنعناها من أي وقت مضى
أنها كاميرا بزاوية عريضة تبلغ دقتها 12 ميجابكسل ،
وهي نفس الكاميرا ذات الزاوية العريضة بالضبط في
10 و 10 من أجهزة Mac ، لذا فهي مستشعر الجيل الجديد الخاص بنا
الذي
يتميز بتثبيت صورة بصري أكبر بوحدات البكسل
ضعف عدد وحدات البكسل البؤري
السريعة بفتحة عدسة F 1.8  عدسة Apple Design
والفلاش الجديد ذو اللونين المحسنين
أيضًا ، وهو يلتقط صورًا جميلة مثل
هذه ، لذلك تم التقاطها من
هاتف iPhone 10 R ، إنه لأمر مذهل أن iPhone 10
R سيأتي بستة ألوان
وبثلاثة أحجام 64 جيجا بايت و 128 جيجا بايت
و  256 جيجا بايت من التخزين
وسيبدأ سعرها من سبعمائة وتسعة وأربعين
دولارًا